foreign university has honored a scientist
who is just nine years old Bobby Wilson is
fascinated by bugs but last year her mission
to catch spotted Lantern flies made national
headlines Bradley Blackburn has the details on
how a frightening encounter led to a celebration
it has red and brown wings with black spots and
nine-year-old Bobby Wilson can tell you exactly
what it is last fall she learned about this
invasive species in school and wanted to help
she found a bug spray recipe on Tick Tock good job
I mix water dish soap and apple cider vinegar she
was using it outside her New Jersey home when a
neighbor called the police a little black woman
walking and spraying stuff on the sidewalks
and trees I don't know what the hell she's
doing scares me though Bobby's mom says it was
racial profiling those exact words in another town
another state I could be grieving Yale University
assistant professor at Joma opara heard Bobby's
story and decided to take this young entomologist
under her Wing oh yeah Bobby belongs here
Bobby is yell she invited Bobby to campus
to meet scientists who look like her
Friday Bobby was back to see the first
spotted lanternfly specimens added to
the Yale Peabody Museum of Natural History
collection those insects were gathered by
Bobby herself how does it make you feel to know
that these bugs are going to be in this Museum
happy and proud a young girl who's
flying high and now has the bug for a
career in science for CBS Saturday morning
Bradley Blackburn New Haven Connecticut
wow turning something awful around
what a way to do it that's right